[Music]  my name is dana perino and i've been at  fox news since april of 2009. my path to  fox news really went through 1600  pennsylvania avenue i never thought that  i would necessarily end up at fox news i  just knew i wanted to be there and then  all of a sudden out of the blue i get a  call asking if i wanted to do this  temporary show for five weeks called the  five hello everyone it's five o'clock on  the east coast and i thought oh my gosh  okay go to live in new york for five  weeks in the middle of the summer  i guess well i called my husband to tell  him and he said congratulations  what do you mean and he said this is  what you always wanted to do your entire  life and 10 years later we are still  doing that awesome show one of the best  things about being at fox is that i've  always felt that i could fully be myself  i've grown up with fox news in my career  from the white house days all the way to  now